i asked
thomas a edison to talk to me about
inventions and he did
inventions now remake the world every 20
years
i wanted edison's forecast of what
inventions are coming next
i wanted his views instead of those of
anyone else
because i believed he was likely to know
more
than anyone else i recalled particularly
a remark that he once made to me
when i am trying to make a thing he said
i always play my blue chips first
i try to think of the biggest thing that
could be done
and then do it
[Music]
on my way to the laboratory i had mapped
out in my mind a list of questions that
i wanted to ask
edison did not wait to see the map he
knew what he wanted to discuss
first what he wanted to discuss first
was money not silver not bank notes
not government certificates gold
he believes gold will not much longer
last
he holds these views because he believes
it is only a question of time
until a way will be discovered to
manufacture
gold the discovery will surely be made
sometime
because the making of gold is a question
only of the proper
combination and treatment of matter
perhaps
radium has the power to convert a cheap
metal into a deer one
radium is a wonderful metal he continued
we know next to nothing about it
the fact of its discovery was made known
to us one morning in the newspapers
news of the discovery of some metal even
more wonderful
may come to us in the newspapers
tomorrow morning
all over the world scientists are
working hard
to try and find out the secrets of
things
every fact we find makes it easier to
find the next
fact nothing that is reasonable is
impossible
and it is reasonable to expect that we
shall find out
how to make gold
this video has been sponsored by babel
the world's number one
language learning app from china to rome
japan to the usa spain to mexico how did
these different cultures connect
well they had translators just a very
confusing time
but luckily these days we have babel
living in spain
i've been a babble user for many years
and it has been a life
saver gone are the days where i wish the
ground to swallow me up in the
supermarket
15 hours of babble for example is equal
to an entire semester of college
language classes
and it's obviously loads easier less
hassle and you can do it in your pajamas
it's great
so if you guys want to be able to chat
away in a different language babel is
the
obvious place to start sign up on this
link to get 50 percent off your first
six months for a limited time only
and then we can speak spanish together
thana horia
[Music]
thanks
edison has very high regard for the
bumblebee
as a flyer he says its wings are
exceedingly small in proportion to the
size and weight of its body
it flies so well only because it uses
its wings
so well moreover he believes we shall
have to learn
wisdom from the bumblebee before we
shall travel in the air very far
very fast or very safely he would apply
the bumblebee principle
to lifting the flying machine and the
present propeller system to driving it
ahead
in his opinion flying machines should be
able to go
straight up airplanes can only go up
as they go ahead suppose you had four
million trained bumblebees
he said attached to wire wickerwork on
which was seated a man
can't you understand that if the
bumblebees were signaled to fly
they would lift the man i believe
mechanical bumblebees
could be attached to a flying machine
that they would lift it straight up
by mechanical bumblebees i mean inclined
planes revolving upon perpendicular
shafts
at tremendous speeds once in the air
ordinary propellers
could be used to drive the machine ahead
edison believes
that the present type of aeroplanes will
soon be discarded and that
bumblebee fliers will carry passengers
at a rate
of 100 miles an hour or more
[Music]
meanwhile transportation upon land he
declares
will be revolutionized the steam
locomotive
is blowing its last blast for millions
of people the next generation of new
yorkers and new englanders
will first hear at school of steam
locomotives
and never will see them unless they go
to some state that has neither much
water power
nor much population water wheels will
make electricity to run all the
railroads that traverse regions in which
there is abundant
water power whole systems like the great
northern will be thus
operated in densely populated states
electric
locomotives will displace steam
regardless of whether water power
is available
[Music]
yet the changes edison foresees in the
methods of transportation
are less radical than the changes he
foresees in the use of iron
and steel steel he says
is destined soon to fall from its high
pinnacle as the skeleton of skyscrapers
to become the material of which
furniture is made of
book covers may also be made of steel
even the pages of books
may be made of steel though edison
regards nickel
as a better substitute for paper here
indeed
is a case where the small end of a
subject is the big end
the imagination is not much taxed by the
suggestion of skyscrapers being made
without steel
but nickel books bound by steel
why not asked edison nickel
will absorb printer's ink a sheet of
nickel
one twenty thousandth of an inch thick
is cheaper
tougher and more flexible than an
ordinary sheet of book paper
a nickel book two inches thick would
contain 40
000 pages such a book would weigh only a
pound
i can make a pound of nickel sheets for
a dollar and a quarter
all furniture will soon be made of steel
said edison
the steel required for a given piece of
furniture costs
only one-fifth as much as the wood would
cost for the same piece of furniture
and polished steel takes a beautiful
finish it can be stained in perfect
imitation of mahogany
walnut cherry maple oak or any other
wood
the babies of the next generation will
sit in steel high chairs
and eat from steel tables they will not
know
what wooden furniture is men who put up
wooden structures are worse lunatics it
is because we use such building
materials
that the fire losses in this country
amount to almost
500 million dollars a year
[Music]
edison had a good deal to do with the
bringing out of the telephone
perhaps he could conceive of something
better than the telephone
something better than the telegraph
better than the
marconi wireless something that would
utilize a new form of which mankind is
not yet conscious
he could conceive of such a force so far
as i know
said he there is no quality of the ether
that will permit us to send wave
impulses
in other than the electrical form but i
have no doubt
that wave impulses can be sent in other
and perhaps better forms
i do know however that the present
telephone is very imperfect
if you want to know how imperfect it is
read the drug market
to a stenographer at the other end of
the wire and see how much of it
she will get the success of the
telephone is due to human
imagination a man is rung up on the
phone
he gets a clue to the identity of the
person who is calling him
and if the subject breached is one with
which he is familiar the rest is easy
but mention a name that the other man
did not expect to hear
and see how quickly he will break in
with a what's that
repeat that name and finally spell it
edison believes that the day will come
when the telephone will leave little to
nothing to the imagination
when it will shout out to proper names
or whisper the quotations from the drug
market
edison calls the brain a meat machine
a machine made of meat he says that the
next generation
will see metal machinery that in
wonderfulness of performance
will almost rival the brain itself
cloth buttons thread tissue paper and
paste board
will be fed into one end of the machine
and suits of clothing
packed in boxes will come out the other
bound books will fall from the press the
machine that takes
in lumber will give out finished
furniture
in other words machinery will make the
parts of things
and put them together instead of merely
making the parts of things for human
hands to put together
invention is in its infancy said edison
infants have to creep before they can
walk
inventors had to begin by inventing
machinery to make only the parts of
things
but the time has now come to take the
next step and invent machinery
that will not only make the parts but
put the parts
together the day of the seamstress
wearily running her seam is almost ended
there is no reason why women should be
made to do what machinery can do better
human labor is slow and expensive even
when it is applied to machinery and
making the parts of things
machine labor is cheap because its
product is so enormous in quantity
many years will not pass before
machinery will make
clothing so cheap that anyone can afford
to have four or five suits of clothes a
[Music]
year
edison believes that the present type of
farmers and the present methods of
farming are destined to disappear
that in place of the present farmer
become a shrewd businessman
i think the coming farmer said edison
will be a man on a seat
beside a push button and some levers
the present trend all point to this
conclusion
we are making wonderful headway twenty
years ago
we knew almost nothing about scientific
agriculture
edison believes that the piling up of
armaments will bring
universal revolution or universal peace
before there can be more than one more
great war
working men he says will not much longer
stand
to be taxed to create great and still
greater armies and navies
if governments don't heed governments
will be destroyed
by their own people in his opinion
governments will heed
by making the hague tribunal the supreme
court
of the world i believe said he
that all england will someday stop at
the sound of
one command and that the command
of a working man
there will be no poverty in the world a
hundred years from now
said edison there is no limit to the
cheapness with which things can be made
the world will soon be flooded with the
cheap products
of machinery not the poor products the
cheap
products
[Music]
why should we expect poverty to continue
asked edison
poverty was for a world that used only
its hands
when men used nothing but their hands
poverty was most intense
now that men have begun to use their
brains poverty is decreasing
poverty is decreasing though we have
been only using our brains a little
while
think how long the world has stood and
then recall that practically everything
we know today that is worthwhile we have
learned within
a hundred years look about you and see
how many things that were worthwhile
were known a hundred years ago
the world flooded with food clothing
shelter and luxuries
what good would it do the people of the
world if a few men should own all these
things
edison had thought of that he realizes
the size of the problem
but he says it is a problem in the
solving of which
neither he nor his kind can help
inventors can make the world rich
only the people can provide the
governmental means for keeping the
riches they make
he believes that people are going to
provide these means
he believes there are stormy days ahead
for the man
who would take what another makes he
believes there will be cracks in the
walls of government
and rips in constitutions that the
working man
the man who will someday say to england
stand still
will compel governments to serve him and
destroy any government
that will not serve him moreover he
believes things
ought to be changed civilization he says
is not on the right basis a few
are getting too much and the rest
not enough there will be some big
experiments
tried in government within the next 50
[Music]
years
you